Collagen proteins normally stick together in groups of three
to form a triple helix. Now this structure is so
important and effective that it's the source of much of
the connective tissue in your body and is by far
the most abundant protein in mammals. In fact, in humans,
collagen makes up about 25 to 30% of total body
protein. That's 25 to 30% of who you are, is
this one protein. Now the very nature of the spiral
here depends on an amino acid called Glycine.
The change we talked about from a couple exercises
back from a glycine to a cysteine causes
enough of a structural shift to weaken the triple
helix significantly. If you weaken this helix you're
going to weaken the very connective tissue around bones. Making
them more prone to breaking. So in this scenario
here, the change from glycine to cysteine that weakens
the helix. Do you think this an is an example of a
loss of function, a gain of function, or no change in function?